JAMES GRIME: It's maths news.
We all love maths news, right?
So recently the Abel Prize
was announced.
The Abel Prize is like the Nobel
Prize for mathematics.
So the winner of this
year's Abel
Prize was Endre Szemeredi.
And he's a Hungarian
mathematician.
It's in recognition of a
career in mathematics.
And so, for that he has won six
million Norwegian krone.
That's about $1 million.
So for this video--
and we always like to attach
a number to our video--
we're going to use the
number 6,000,000.
DAVID HODGE: The prize itself
only started in 2003.
But it's now being seen as the
mathematics Nobel Prize.
There was a prize called the
Fields Medal for mathematics,
which has been around
much longer.
JAMES GRIME: There's the Fields
medal which is really
for young mathematicians.
Young mathematicians,
for us, is under 40.
The Abel Prize has no
restriction like that.
So it is more directly
comparable
to the Nobel Prizes.
DAVID HODGE: There is a fair
amount of publicity about it.
So it's awarded in Norway,
and some people fly
over for the ceremony.
JAMES GRIME: There is no Nobel
Prize for mathematics.
There are some stories about
that, and maybe I'll save
those to the end.
I like to end with
an anti-climax.
DAVID HODGE: So surname
Szemeredi--
S-Z-E-M-E-R-E-D-I, first
name Endre--
so quite difficult to pronounce,
like many of the
Hungarian mathematicians.
He's now in his 70s.
He's published over 200 papers
in a wide variety of areas.
In particular, lots of
applications to graph theory,
and applications to number
theory, and including computer
science, sorting algorithms.
I'll talk today about some of
the applications in what
sounds a bit like number theory
to do with counting
sets of integers with
certain properties.
So I'm going to talk about
what's now called Szemeredi's
theorem, though it used to
be called the Erdos-Turan
conjecture, which stood
for 30 or 40 years.
And, because of the importance
of the result, and the ways in
which Szemeredi proved it,
the result has now
taken on his name.
JAMES GRIME: One of his big
theorems is now named after
Szemeredi, so it's Szemeredi's
theorem.
And it's about finding structure
in randomness.
So this is what we're
going to look at.
We're going to look at something
called arithmetic
progressions.
DAVID HODGE: Integers--
we're thinking about
patterns within integers.
So suppose I take a
list of integers.
I'll try and list
a few of them.
1, 6, 7--
there, I've chosen
six numbers.
But, unfortunately, what's
happened is I've chosen them
in such a way that 1, 4, 7,
10 form what's called an
arithmetic progression.
So it's a progression where the
gaps between the numbers
is the same at every step.
What we're going to try and do
now is we're going to try to
choose the numbers, and
avoid these patterns.
So I'm going to choose some
numbers between 1 and 15.
Let's focus just on patterns
of length three.
So a pattern where you've got a
number, a second number, and
a third number, where the gap
between the first and second
number is the same as
the gap between the
second and third number.
Like 1, 4, 7 or 4, 7, 10.
So I'll choose 1.
I'll choose 2.
Now, I can't choose 3, because
I'd have a pattern
immediately.
So let's choose 4.
I can't choose 6, because then
we'd have 2, 4, 6, which forms
a pattern of three in a row
with the same difference.
So I can't have 6.
Can I have 5?
Yes, I'll have 5.
I can't have 7, because 1,
4, 7 would be a pattern.
And I'm starting to struggle
to find numbers.
I have to start going to 8.
So I go to 8.
Have I managed it?
Oh, no, I've already failed.
I tried, but I failed, because
2, 5, 8 was a pattern.
It's actually quite difficult
to choose numbers without
avoiding certain patterns.
We're going to try to move
towards what Szemeredi's
theorem says.
So let's try and avoid 3.
So let's choose k.
That's going to be equal to 3.
That's the length of
a sequence I'm
going to try and avoid.
And the rules are, we're going
to have to choose numbers from
the list 1, 2, 3, up to some
enormous number, n--
very large number, n-- for
example, 1,000,000.
So we're going to try and choose
numbers from 1 to a
million, just like we chose
numbers before.
And we're going to try and
avoid having any three
somewhere which have got
a common difference.
Now, obviously we're not going
to do that now, because there
are far too many numbers
to choose from.
But what Szemeredi said is,
actually, it's surprisingly
few numbers that you're allowed
to choose before
you're forced to
have a pattern.
One way to describe his theorem
is, I ask you for some
percentage, and you
give me 1%.
1% is going to be what
percentage of the numbers I'm
going to offer you, that you're
going to have to choose.
Let's go more advanced.
Let's choose k is 4.
That means we're going to have
to try and avoid having four
numbers in the sequence,
somewhere, which have all got
a common difference--
like 10, 20, 30, 40, or 100,
1,000, 1,900, 2,800.
I could also put in 45,
50, 55, and 60.
And I've messed up.
And what Szemeredi said--
so here's Szemeredi.
He comes along and gives us some
completely insanely large
number, which might be 10
to the 10 to the 10.
This is going to be how
many numbers you
get to choose from.
So I'm now going to give
you the exercise.
You've got to choose 1% of the
numbers from this list, and
try and avoid a sequence
of length 4.
You won't manage it.
Szemeredi's cleverly--
his theorem says that if you
chose any percentage, and any
k, he can come back with a
number that says, if you
choose even 1% of those
numbers, you will have
accidentally, at some point,
chosen four numbers in your
list with a common difference
between them.
So you probably say, this is
all very well, but 1% maybe
was too many.
And k equals 4-- that
was quite a short
list to try and avoid.
Actually, even if you'd given me
a ludicrous percentage-- if
you'd given me a tiny
percentage--
0.001%.
So at the end of this game, I'm
going to give you a list
of numbers, and you can choose
0.001% of them-- that's very,
very few of them.
And even if we'd then chosen
k to be something else,
something much larger--
say k is 100.
k is 100 means all you've got
to do is avoid having 100
numbers where the common
difference is the
same all the way along.
Now, you'd think that was
really easy to avoid.
You'd think you could
manage that.
Szemeredi says, OK, give
me your percentage.
Give me your k.
He'll go away, come back from
his theorem, and he's going to
give you another number
on the end.
His number's going to
be even larger--
some completely insane number.
But it's a number.
You won't manage
to avoid this--
what seems like a very
unlikely thing.
And this is true for any
percentage and for any k.
MALE SPEAKER (OFFSCREEN): Did
Szemeredi come up with an
equation that you could plug
that number into, and that
number into, to give
you that number?
Is there an equation?
DAVID HODGE: If only.
No.
So, a lot of the results in this
area have this strangely
non-constructive
proof to them.
So the actual proof, itself,
doesn't even
give you the number.
It purely says, there
must be a number.
MALE SPEAKER (OFFSCREEN): You
said if I came up with any
percentage, and any k, Szemeredi
would come back to
me with a number.
Are you now saying Szemeredi,
actually, he
couldn't give me a number.
He could just tell me
a number exists.
DAVID HODGE: He could tell
you a number exists.
There have been results since
his work for which people have
managed to give an upper
band on this number.
In which case, they could,
now, give you a number.
MALE SPEAKER (OFFSCREEN): The
one thing that troubles me
here is, there are an
infinite number of
numbers, aren't there?
DAVID HODGE: Yep.
MALE SPEAKER (OFFSCREEN): So I
could have told you that no
matter what you put there, and
no matter what you put there,
there'll be a number there
eventually, because there are
an infinite number of numbers
that could go there.
So why has Szemeredi
been clever?
DAVID HODGE: So suppose you
took all the numbers.
Suppose we go 1, 2, 3--
now this list goes on forever.
So this is all the integers
you know.
What Szemeredi's result tells
us is that if you gave me a
percentage--
so, again, let's choose
a percentage.
This time we'll go for something
slightly bigger--
0.01%.
If I asked you to choose a list
of integers, it's going
to be a very long list,
because you've
got to choose 0.01%.
You're still going to have to
choose infinitely many, but
you're going to choose about 1
in 10,000 of all the numbers.
What Szemeredi's result tells
you is you are going to
accidentally create
progressions,
lists of all lengths--
not just length 4, and 100, but
any possible length will
appear in your list if all you
did was choose numbers, to
arrange to choose about
a 10,000th of them.
JAMES GRIME: So what I really
liked about this, though, is
that this theorem was used
to prove another result--
pretty much similar--
but about prime numbers.
Now, the prime numbers are
actually quite rare.
They're unpredictable
and rare.
So they have density zero.
Now, you can't use Szemeredi's
theorem to prove the same
result with the prime numbers,
because Szemeredi's theorem
was about things that had
greater than zero density.
But you could use his theorem
in the proof of this
statement--
the prime numbers have
arithmetic progressions.
So let's take the list
of prime numbers.
We know the prime numbers.
They're 2, and 3, and 5.
They go on forever.
They're rare and
unpredictable.
But still you can find
sequences, like the arithmetic
progressions, of length 100,
of length 1,000,000,
whatever you want.
And that is surprising.
There is structure
in the randomness
of the prime numbers.
An arithmetic sequence
in the prime numbers.
Let's pick--
I'm going to start with 5--
that's a prime number.
And I'm going to add on 6.
That's 11.
I'm going to add on 6 again.
That is 17.
That's a prime number.
Add on 6 again.
That's 23.
Add on 6 again--
that's 29.
And that is an arithmetic
progression of length five
just using prime numbers.
The common difference is six.
In this case, they are
called sexy primes.
We're going to talk about
that, aren't we?
Now, the theorem doesn't
guarantee what the common
difference will be.
You can't specify it.
It doesn't tell you
where to start it.
It doesn't even tell you
how to find them.
But what I can guarantee you
is that I can give you a
progression of any length.
I can give you a progression
of length a million-- a
billion, even.
MALE SPEAKER (OFFSCREEN):
But you can't tell me
what the gap is?
JAMES GRIME: I can't tell
you what the gap is.
But imagine a progression of
a billion, just using prime
numbers, where they have the
common difference the same all
the way through.
MALE SPEAKER (OFFSCREEN):
And that's there?
JAMES GRIME: And that
is in there.
And that is guaranteed
to be in there.
I can't tell you what
it is, but it's
guaranteed to be in there.
MALE SPEAKER (OFFSCREEN):
Who figured that out?
JAMES GRIME: Oh, who
figured that out?
Oh, the prime number version?
Sorry.
That was figured out by a
Cambridge mathematician called
Tim Gowers.
And he's around here
somewhere.
He'll be in one of
these offices.
MALE SPEAKER (OFFSCREEN):
Really?
JAMES GRIME: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER (OFFSCREEN):
Well, let's go ask him.
JAMES GRIME: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER (OFFSCREEN):
Is this just
crosswords and Sudoku?
Is this just mathematicians
being unimaginably clever?
Or is there a practical reason
for Szemeredi to do this?
DAVID HODGE: So some of the
final results-- like this
result-- it's not obvious
this has any particular
applications.
But what's definitely true is
that in order to get to these
results, Szemeredi,
himself, proved
particularly one famous result--
what's called Szemeredi's
regularity lemma, which is now
being used in a number of
different areas of maths, not
just this fairly small area of
trying to count progressions.
That's particularly one of
the reasons why he's been
recognized.
It's not just because he's
done one big thing.
But he's done a number
of big things.
And even to prove those big
things, he's developed a whole
new area of theory, which
has been used by many
people since him.
JAMES GRIME: So there is no
Nobel Prize for maths.
Now, the story that is told in
maths departments around the
world is that Nobel, he didn't
give a Nobel Prize for
mathematics-- or didn't set
one up-- because he hated
mathematicians, and because
his wife ran off with a
mathematician.
And that's the story that
is told in math
departments all over.
The only problem is,
he wasn't married.
And it's not true.
It's not true.
He, I guess, though--
Nobel--
didn't appreciate mathematics
enough to give it a prize.
He was interested in physics
and chemistry.
There isn't a Nobel Prize
for biology, either.
So it's that reason.
It's less exciting.
I told you I wanted to end
with an anti-climax.